Це мій вклад у цю перемогу, в яку ми віримо.
Я не можу залишатися осторонь, хоча мені вже стільки років, що можна було б і відпочити.
Якщо ти не йдеш безпосередньо туди в окопи воювати, то допомагай!
Чи грошима, чи волонтер.
Я хоч своєю маленькою роботою, але "закрию" хоч одного солдата чи хоч одну машину.
Хоч якийсь шматочок, але виживе.
Попри свій поважний вік ці жінки вірять, що дочекаються перемоги України.
І як волонтерки чим можуть підтримують ЗСУ.
Історії цих українських пенсіонерок надихають.
У свої 78 пані Тая з Ворзеля на Київщині підтримує українське військо.
Спершу робила це як партизанка під час окупації рідного селища, тепер - як волонтерка.
Двадцять четверте: "Війна! Кацапи - сволоти!"
"9-го приїхали кацапи, 11-13 одиниць техніки".
Те, що баба бачила, те і записувала.
Їде звідти колона: то я і записую:
там стільки-то танків, БМП, бензовоз, бортова, поїхали куди і в який бік, в який час.
Під час окупації Ворзеля пенсіонерка щодня записувала дані про техніку росіян.
І потім передавала їх ЗСУ через волонтерів.
Також вона віддала майже всю хату під склад гуманітарки і годувала людей в окупації і після неї.
Ось бабуся приготувала справжні котлетки! Ммм!
Беріть ще!
Ось ця бабуся відстояла Ворзель! Ворогів бачила своїми очима!
Вона погодилася одразу допомагати! Безстрашна!
Ніколи мені не сказала "ні".
Багато людей не хотіли брати на себе відповідальність,
ми зверталися до місцевих людей, чи можемо залишити якісь продукти.
Вони казали: "Ні! Після вас сюди приїздять танки".
Після звільнення Київщини пані Тая почала збирати гроші на ЗСУ з власної пенсії.
Та коли назбирала 10 тисяч гривень, її обікрали.
Про історію "бабусі-волонтерки" розповіли у соцмережах.
І за лічені дні в Україні та Литві зібрали всю суму і передали пенсіонерці.
Пані Тая віддала кошти військовим на купівлю дронів.
Слава Україні! Хай воно вам на поміч буде! І на перемогу!
БПЛА уже на фронті, звітують волонтери.
Снаряд від баби Таї!
Ой!
Туди їм і дорога! Я б все разом з Кремлем!
Я б їх всіх! Вони б у мене всі розмовляли українською!
Пані Тая має намір продовжувати допомагати ЗСУ - аж до перемоги!
А ще як волонтерка вчить усіх охочих української мови.
Якщо ти не йдеш безпосередньо туди в окопи воювати, то допомагай!
Чи грошима, чи як волонтер!
А це - 83-річна Романа Маліщук з Миколаєва.
Вона вирішила допомагати ЗСУ ще рік тому,
проте волонтерські організації спершу відмовляли пенсіонерці через вік.
Я скрізь шукала таку організацію, але мені всі відмовляли,
тому що спитають скільки років і відповідають: "Ми вам передзвонимо".
І так і не передзвонювали.
А тут наш мер Сєнкевич дав оголошення ось з цим номером телефону.
Я по цьому номеру телефону сюди прийшла.
І тут мене не запитали скільки мені років, а сказали:
"Будь ласка, приходьте, ми для вас знайдемо роботу".
Відтоді пані Романа майже щодня працює у цьому волонтерському центрі.
Літня жінка виготовляє сітки для українських військових.
Матеріально я не можу нічим допомогти, бо я давно вже пенсіонерка.
Тому я й знайшла цю організацію, щоб допомагати хоч чимось.
Я хоч своєю маленькою роботою, але "закрию" хоч одного солдата чи хоч одну машину.
Хоч якийсь шматочок, але виживе.
Той, що буде закритий нашими сітками.
Я роблю одне й те саме. Ми ріжемо матеріали на ось такі смужки.
З цих смужок, якщо вони маленькі…
Ми їх зв'язуємо, зшиваємо. І тоді плетуть сітки.
У Миколаєві у жінки не залишилося рідних.
Пенсіонерка живе сама, тож волонтерський центр став для неї другим домом.
Тут вона відсвяткувала і свій 83-й день народження.
Тут прекрасно. Я навіть не думала, що так.
Прихожу, а тут і стіл накритий, і подарунки, і квіти.
І навіть депутат приїхав привітати.
То було для мене важко пережити, тому що я ніколи не потрапляла в такі обставини, щоб мене хтось честував.
Все в житті буває. І це треба пережити.
Пані Роману вважають однією з найпродуктивніших волонтерок.
83-річна пенсіонерка працює нарівні з молодшими на 20-30 років колегами.
Допомагати ЗСУ жінка планує аж до закінчення війни.
Нині найбільша мрія пенсіонерки - дожити до перемоги України.
Коли я не працювала, то була настільки хвора, що мені не хотілося з ліжка вставати.
А як я сюди прийшла, то з першого дня в мене енергія взялася.
Стільки енергії, що в мене, напевно, в років 40 вже не було такої енергії, як зараз.
Зараз я на ентузіазмі тримаюся.
Правда, буває, що тиск підскакує. Вік, вже нічого не зробиш.
Але я стараюся триматися і буду триматися до останнього дня війни.
Перемоги обов'язково дочекаюся.
Українська акторка Галина Яблонська вдруге за життя бачить війну.
Нині у свої 95 років вона активно займається волонтерством:
регулярно відвідує поранених захисників у шпиталях і влаштовує творчі виступи для військових.
Це мій вклад у цю перемогу, в яку ми віримо.
Я не можу залишатися осторонь, хоча мені вже стільки років, що можна було б і відпочити.
А я собі не можу цього дозволити, адже я знаю, що після моїх виступів мені дякують…
Знаєте, я відчуваю, що те, що я роблю, воно потрібне, воно підтримує, воно дає людям якусь більшу віру.
У роки Другої світової війни пані Галина була підлітком.
Акторка й досі пам’ятає жахіття тієї війни.
Але каже, що теперішні злочини росіян ще страшніші.
Школи були знищені, але був сільськогосподарський технікум.
Готували робочу силу, вони забирали на роботу в Німеччину.
Але такої руйнації, як зараз…
І це ще одне підтвердження тому, що Путлер…
Путін знає, що він тут не буде господарем.
Бо якби він це знав - так не руйнував би.
Під час Другої світової війни акторка ледь не загинула.
Коли мені хазяйка сказала, що підемо в бомбосховище, то я подумала:
"Боже, навіщо мені те бомбосховище? Я така маленька. Що та бомба саме на мене?".
І саме на мене вона впала, мене засипало і я вже прощалася зі світом.
І тут чую, хтось по мені ходить, по тому завалу. "Тут хтось є".
І вони почали мене розгрібати.
Розгребли руки, і я потім своїми руками, поздирала нігті, щоб вдихнути.
Галина Яблонська працювала з легендарним актором і режисером Гнатом Юрою.
Відома акторка виступає на сцені майже 90 років.
Нині найбільша мрія пані Галини - перемога України.
Ця нація виживе і стане законодавцем.
В Україну будуть приїздити, в Україні будуть шукати…
Тому що таких пісень, як у нас, ніде у світі нема.
Таких вишиванок, таких костюмів.
І я думаю, що Європа навіть приїде до нас
і буде вчитися нашому вмінню любити цей світ.